hi guys thank you so much for coming
today my name is Amanda and my question
is in season 11 when cast took over the
vessel from Lucifer what do you think
his punishment was Jasper's punishment
what was his punishment um I mean I
think we saw that play out his
punishment was partly that he was
inhabited by Lucifer which is in and of
itself a punishment
I think the cast made that choice
because he kind of felt like he had
failed he had let everyone down and he
was really down on himself at that point
so it was a kind of a kamikaze move
where it was a bit of self-sacrifice and
a bit of self-loathing effort in there
that I think and compelled him to make
that choice but in I think this
particular instance the punishment was
the act itself what that was and also
Sam and Dean now regularly with him with
towels on and off set sounds like a win
to me all right next question over here
so I've been a big fan since I saw the
promo in 2005 so this is amazing thanks
guys o-over you in 2005 um I just
started high school okay I was looking
you you look very young I was like wait
a second she was Washington she was like
five years old uh I'm 23 awesome
um so my question is open to everyone
and I was just wondering if since
starting the show um you've well I'm
wondering on your take on the
supernatural personally and since you
started the show if you for example been
camping and thought oh wow is that I
wouldn't eat go over I'll say something
funny um
I haven't seen a windy go yet but Jenson
and I so we both live in Austin with our
families we walked into like yeah we
walked into it was like a restaurant or
a bar or something and somebody sitting
there look at us and goes damn are you
here to like kill ghosts or something
like like they seemed genuinely
concerned they were like man the
Winchesters are here there's like a
there's a demon in the back yeah like
holding EMF detectors well like we got
it don't worry you're safe oh every now
and again I don't think anything happen
to me legit but every now and again if
the lights flicker or if it gets cold
I'm like don't worry guys I got it yeah
I kind of figured that even though it's
kind of like I'm not a doctor but I play
one on TV ah it and I feel like I feel
like the paranormal and the supernatural
would probably be smart enough to steer
clear of two guys who have spent over a
decade portraying hunters they may have
picked up a trick or two and I feel like
they're probably going to steer clear of
us that being said if we'd ever do run
into an issue I feel like I could handle
myself
cut to Jensen running screaming
screaming
well you heard you that crunch it cuts a
yellow fever you are it's just a cat
Jensen it's just a cat scare is scary
for any experience in the underworld
listening today Jensen Ackles just laid
down the challenge so there you go ha ha
ha ha bring it I am fat Castiel the
angel of Doritos
hi my name's Colin I'm all the way from
Texas we do need to introduce that
character that said Andrew are you
taking jokes
no no I think you look to Rita's winner
so I have a question and if I'm able to
ask it if not I have a backup question
but in honor of season 12 I actually had
a very special question for my
girlfriend yes yes oh my gosh sure yeah
will you come up here that was your
question
oh that was your question you gives it
up how much does she know about the show
so we've been watching your show from
the very beginning you want to share
this very special moment with our
friends and family here at comic-con
we love you all thank you very much for
everything that you do and I want to say
to you in my love I've loved you since
the very first moment that I saw you you
were the Sun that brightens my day and
you were the moon of my life I can't
think of anybody else I would want by my
side slaying zombies in the killing
vampires
and killing demons and whatever else is
out there
Wendy goes those things so what I'm
trying to ask you I think this comes on
let's try it out
okay Ashley Elizabeth Rhodes will you
marry me
kiss her kiss her all right get a room
good so we'll get a room thank you guys
what was the backup question I want to
know what the backup question was so the
backup questioning us man a bag of
Doritos thanks a lot she said yes that
was a nail-biter
so my backup question was for several
seasons we were trying to figure out who
had the deeper voice was it Cass or
wasn't Dean so I don't know what's in
for I think unfortunately I think Mark
Sheppard takes the cake on that he had
his vocal cords surgically altered and
in all fairness um
Mark Sheppard also talks about 20 hours
a day so I think it's very warm down so
it's just very much definitely it's
definitely worn down um love love love
can we get a voice off congrats guys
congratulations yeah we should not both
seeking medical attention for the
fortress trying to keep up with a
recharge ship to keep the throat down
here good idea I haven't done my vocal
warm-ups but I'll do my best as a line
that you guys know I'm the one who
gripped you tight and raised you from
perdition
what he he he ever done he sounds like
that in the morning uh how do you know
I quit my crock Ellis it's a Claddagh
that was the back out course I still
can't work out why that was the backup
question it's like if she says no I want
to know who had the deeper voice I mean
how does that go together
why were you gonna pick one of the two
of them and ask them instead it would
have however it would have been funny if
he was like I'd like to ask my
girlfriend a question and he raises the
box like oh no no don't do that cuz then
he'd be like oh I was just kidding haha
press the sbatch Congrats guys
thanks for the question yeah I think
it's a beautiful thing when a
satanically theme television show can
bring people together that yeah that may
have been one of the first wedding
proposals that included talking of the
people you're going to kill together
we're gonna kill demons I want him as
one of the demons on the show I like him
yes alright you right there lady hi um
thank you guys for being here don't know
how to [ __ ] you been already married so
Jensen posted a photo for Jared's
birthday happy late birthday by the way
thank you
and it had your kids and said you guys
were gonna have um yours raising a
future generation of hunters and so my
question is what would you guys like
that to look like if all your kids had a
spinoff and would you guys like to come
back as like a Bobby or something
a lot of kids okay we're gonna milk this
thing for all penetration season 23 yeah
that would make a good prequel your
children thank you
there they're already kind of a gang as
it is um as some of you know jared has
two sons I have a daughter and the other
day my daughter were talking about his
two boys and I was like are they are
they your friends and she goes another
month boys she's just turned three and
so they we might not have a choice in
the matter they might just be doing
whatever they're gonna do and and I
assume that you know they're gonna want
to stay in the family business awesome
um yeah I agree with that yes sir thanks
darling
I moose it's sasquatch you're taller
friend I know I reckon yeah you're hard
to miss security so this goes for any of
you want to answer the question uh
what's a facet in your characters
personas that you haven't explored yet
or you haven't explored as deeply as
you'd like to and how would you like to
do that killing billions of people you
have explored all right you know I will
say I think maybe at the robber Richard
made the joke earlier that there are not
a lot of scenarios that we could
legitimately bring up and as a future
episode that hasn't already happened but
there is and having mom back is
something really interesting for me as a
person as Jared Padalecki to explore but
also her Sam Winchester seeing these
guys Sam and Dean they even though the
group with the father they kind of grew
up on their own because their father was
one-track minded he was after his asel
it was after yellow-eyed demon he wanted
exact vengeance and so they kind of
raised each other
um you know Dean raised Sam more than
the opposite being the older brother but
they never really had a proper family
dynamic as far as them being sons we've
seen these guys as heroes we've seen
them sacrificing for each other for
people that don't know we've seen them
out of their own lone wolves rogues but
we haven't really seen them in this
position where cuz even when we saw Sam
just to talk about my own journey every
when we saw him with his father he had a
very contentious relationship it was
more like it wasn't like Oh dad like I
love you it was like dad like I want to
like how dare you you know looking back
at my childhood like you put up 45 under
my pillow like that's messed up so
seeing his mother somebody he loves and
looks up to and getting to be a boy
again is gonna be really interesting and
I'm glad we get to explore that know um
Ruth and Sam we haven't heard from you
in a little bit what about you any
facets to your character that we have a
teen Ruth I I'd like to explore the
toyboy facet tor toy boy toy boy facet
of ruin his personality leave me
it's boy toy in America boy toy maybe
the personal masseuse area okay all
right lalala humph something like that
okay okay I'm mmm well I think that as
Mary it's pretty much anything except
like the perfect mom persona like
everything else is open cuz that's all
it's been so far is just sort of cookies
um
and so oh yeah really so just being a
person a fully actualized person I want
to see and I think we will but I'd like
to see the hunter side of Mary and and
it'll be interesting to see the
similarities between what what and how
she deals with supernatural and and how
the boys deal with it because she is
their mother and so those kind of
similarities might be really fun to
explore I think that'd be cool all right
young man last question you own it
Oh God no pressure no pressure ah this
is about the fan fiction episode from
season 10 is is it based off a real fan
fiction for Supernatural it's a great
question Andrew it was not based off a
specific fan fiction but I think it was
based off a lot of things that were
aware of from our fans on social media
and things like that where you guys are
great and that episode was really kind
of a tribute to you and I'm glad people
liked it so much this has been a
fantastic panel a gentleman parting
words final thoughts
look at me oh go ahead Bob this is a
giver no I think only parting thought
was is I don't think you ever get into a
year twelve if you don't have incredible
fans like you people out there not only
with the you know ratings of the show
and all the support but that you
encouraged us to keep making the show as
original as we can and to not retread
storylines and and not sit on our
laurels but to keep the show fresh and I
think you know to get up every day
especially for me being here from the
beginning and to try to do that you have
to draw an inspiration from the fan base
and what you guys expect from us so you
know we we think season 12 is is a great
testament to you and we thank you for
that
well said well said thank you ladies and
gentlemen Supernatural season 12
you